Kamala Harris who was polling at one
percent in her own party when she
dropped out of the race last time she's
starting to talk about what it might be
like you're 58 now if you win the second
term as you and the president are
running to do he would be 86 at the end
of it The Wall Street Journal had a poll
showing two-thirds of Democrats say Joe
Biden is too old to run again
are you prepared to be
commander-in-chief yes I am if necessary
but Joe Biden is going to be fine and
let me tell you something I work with
Joe Biden every day
the work that under Joe Biden's
leadership our Administration has
accomplished is transformative I think
the American people most of all want a
leader who actually gets things done
listen I will give credit where
creditors do she strung together two
sentences that actually made sense so
that's worth something uh Alex this
thing like Joe Biden will be fine it's
just it's just ridiculous because a he's
obviously not fine on face value but
also he it's one trip it's one broken
hip away from ending like it could
literally end while we are talking right
now
well I think they're going to put them
through some sort of kind of humiliation
ritual and make them step down because
all of Hunter Biden's crimes I mean
everybody knows the laptop's real even
though all of the social media companies
you know came together to say that that
was Russian disinformation so at some
point I think the DNC is not going to
keep defending Joe Biden they're going
to say hey we made you president you
know
we did you a favor now you just need to
go on and they're probably going to the
Future president probably is going to
Pardon him Kamala Harris I know this is
total conspiracy but I think that
they're going to do something to
humiliate Joe Biden because Obama does
not like Joe Biden in my opinion and I
think the future president it would
probably be Michelle Obama if she didn't
have a dong so yeah I don't know I mean
I just I don't have a lot of Hope in uh
Joe Biden in the future but uh he's
definitely not running in 2024.
I'm going to not ask Isabel about that
remark rather
um
nobody likes Kamala and the Democrats
have a real problem with that don't they
they do she's completely unelectable I
don't know if either of you have ever
seen the TV show Veep but I think we are
headed for an almost plot for plot
re-enaction of what's happening on my
favorite Washington DC show the
president will step down within the last
year for whatever reason maybe he has a
stroke maybe it's a fallen bad hip maybe
he passes away I mean at literally
anything is possible between now and
2024 obviously the vice president Kamala
Harris will become president but she
will be unelectable by her own party in
the primaries the exact same way faux
president Selena Meyer was in the TV
show and some Grand hero will sweep in
at the last moment to save the day to
save America from radical Maga white
supremacist extremism and I actually
think you're right on the nose Alex I've
been predicting it would be a Michelle
Obama for a very very long time they're
putting her on all of the late night
comedy shows on all of the lifestyle fun
podcasts not to talk about politics but
to talk about the kids being grown up
where they're going on vacation what
cocktail they made at dinner last night
humanizing the Obamas in a really
relatable way very intentionally leading
into the next election and God help us
solve my other prediction is that Gavin
Newsom likely will be the nominee for
vice president of the United States
sorry Dave I know you just fled
California
but they're doing the same thing with
him making sure he's very likable
relatable electable especially on social
media yeah let me show you one more clip
of Kamala because she's she's ready
for the election you will win we will
win re-election
there's too much at stake and the
American people know it
Alex I can't believe it this is the
election where there's too much at stake
I've always been waiting for the
election when somebody would tell me
there's a lot at stake here and if we
don't vote for them all hell's going to
break loose